[Music]
so the other person that we haven't
covered in a while and he was actually
patient zero um for all this oof
was a david bond david bond
who not to get too much detail but i'll
just say this
he really doesn't like us and we haven't
covered this guy in over a year okay i
looked at it
um well what he's into now because his
pickup artistry work at least doesn't
look like it's doing great maybe it is i
don't know
um he's doing he's doing uh coin stuff
crypto stuff
so uh you won't believe how much money
we raised uh this is of course david
coin kickstart why would you need if
you're such a crypto
genius why would you need yeah whatever
so i was just telling mark about a
really crazy story i read a few months
ago and he had never heard about this
discover card actually blocked all of
its customers
from donating to a very specific
crowdfunding
campaign this kid named kyle rittenhouse
got
banned from gofundme
[Music]
yeah apparently there was this kid from
wisconsin i don't know he's trying to
raise
money i don't know for college or
something i don't know i didn't really
read the story
so they moved to another crowdfunding
platform and discover card
decided to block all customers from
donating to his campaign
suddenly someone in a tower far away
pushed a button
and said you can't spend your own money
on this this is good you've really got
your finger on the pulse huh
specific thing hold on hold on uh i'll
tell you what
real quick if you don't mind uh i gotta
grab my phone uh
if you don't mind i'd like to make a
phone i'm gonna go call dick masterson
eight months ago
let's see if i could get that time
machine fired up got me thinking about
flip starter so for those of you who
don't know flipstarter is a bitcoin cash
kickstarter platform and it is very very
interesting now one of the issues
with platforms like gofundme or
kickstarter
is they are centralized they are highly
political
there are countless
i have the question for you and please
tell me if i'm wrong if i'm wrong i'll
apologize
but i want you to look at his bed is
there a yellow stain on his bed
look at look by the sec look by the
right side of his of the bed yeah but
that looks like it's light maybe
okay okay but i am seeing black
stains as examples of people having
their gofundme shut down
because go no that's not light because
the light well maybe you might remember
the lamps you might be right gofundme
just doesn't agree with it
all you have to do is just type in
gofundme shutdown
and you can just scroll through tons and
tons and tons of stories
now what's really interesting about
flipstarter is
even people who are really into crypto
have no idea
about this thing and i because you just
made it i kind of have reservations
about talking about it because i feel
like it's a little bit of an
undiscovered secret
so it's a very look at what he does he's
trying to use the game that he teaches
for his pickup stuff
on you guys look i don't want hey guys
this is a secret okay
i don't want anybody to know about this
simple interface wait let me see
something here get it back up for a
second this is his website right
back secret so it's a very simple
it's not even a secure url
it's not so i'm sorry well but yeah but
i mean that's
no it's a [ __ ] your money's in there
what's up money it's cryptocurrency rice
which is funny
it's encrypted
buddy you could have at least got an
https
for your [ __ ] website yeah we have
that for our website and nobody puts
any information on our website that's
worth the [ __ ]
but you still get it i think it costs
like an extra two bucks a year
right isn't it something stupid like
that isn't it like when you get your
your domain bill like every every couple
of years they're like
uh and look we're gonna it's a secure uh
security certificate it's gonna run you
like four bucks
for the three years and you're like yeah
that's fine let's throw that in there
simple interface uh holy crap
jesus okay so this person raised 1 000
bitcoin cash i love how he's pretending
that this isn't his website
jesus christ this person raised guys by
the way this really got this guy
who by the way must be really handsome
and must have a lot of pretty
girlfriends this dude here raised
that's funny but do you like how he's
pretending like he's not involved with
it or has some sort of
stake in it you know cash
which at the time of recording is 650
000 and this was raised 20 days ago
so you can see this is what they're
trying to raise you can see the donors
and you can also see little notes
it's a very very simple platform but
what's really cool about it is
because it's utilizing cryptocurrency no
one can stop it
no one can block it there's even a girl
here in
bangkok they could they could shut your
website down
then there would be no portal whoever
owns a domain yeah
there would be no portal in which to go
and donate
so you're actually better off just
making it
hear me out guys don't listen to this
you're better off making a website
yourself and say hey if you want to
donate
via crypto or whatever here's my wallet
addresses
and then people can just click a button
and they'll it'll open up a thing and
it'll show your wallet address
and then they can just send you the
amount that they want to pledge
whoa whoa
dude had a successful flip starter so
let me guys let me show you guys that
here's
a flip starter that was ran in thailand
uh this girl just said hey i'm gonna do
all these cool things
wait a minute go back go back go back go
back to the one he said that was run in
thailand because he was
showing an article he was showing an
archive
he was showing a way back machine
archive for a crypto fundraiser
in thailand gee i wonder what they were
raising money for
well i don't want to make any crazy
accusations but who knows i'm not making
crazy accusations i'm only pointing out
that this person apparently made a
website where he was raising money
for a thing in thailand and when he went
oh this is a thing in thailand he was
looking at a wayback machine thing
which means that whoever started that
fundraiser
didn't want money given to him he wanted
cryptocurrency because it's not as
traceable
and then this person apparently deleted
that website
because he didn't want a trace of that
fundraiser on the internet
i'm not that's not an accusation i'm not
saying it's anything untoward or illegal
i'm only telling you what it appears
this person did which is very shady
looking
and block it there's even a girl here in
bangkok who had a successful flip
starter so let me guys
let me show you guys that here's a a
flip starter that was ran in thailand uh
this girl just
you see that did you see that
mark yeah marketing and promo for
promotion of bitcoin cash in thailand
huh
uh this girl just said hey i'm gonna do
all these cool things what do you guys
think is it a good idea
and you can see that she raised 57
bitcoin cash
so in this video we are going to show
you guys how to run a flip starter and
mark and i are even going to run a flip
starter for you guys to show you how it
works it's really cool but it's going to
be for a very
ambitious amount of money we were
thinking we're gonna run
it for you yeah
getting like a thousand bitcoin cash
maybe ten thousand bitcoin cash i think
now i'm probably so why are you doing
bitcoin cash and not bitcoin bitcoin
cash
you do bitcoin you don't do bitcoin cash
i would say yes for those sorts of
things
uh bitcoin cash is really great to trade
because
it it's more it it
it goes along with bitcoin in price but
it does fluctuate more
so like it'll go up like if bitcoin goes
up like five percent
all of a sudden bitcoin cash might shoot
up like
eight percent real quick and you can
make a little bit more money if you're
trading
but yeah if you're just like collecting
funds and you want to be able to get
those funds
i would say bitcoin would be the solid
one to use
well let's watch him exploring nicaragua
so again literal street walkers not not
making any um
well i don't know what they are i'm just
you know it's weird
you know at least at least when i see
frank hassell
with a gopro on his head it brings me a
feeling of joy
excite you know what i mean like when i
see frank castle rocking the gopro on
his forehead i get excited
when i see him wearing it i'm like oh
that's [ __ ] cool
that is so weird
why is that weird what's weird about it
this guy in my opinion is not very
talented yeah and he doesn't have like a
very deep vocabulary
you know like he's just wow man that's
weird
that's crazy seizure chavez is good or
bad
you know not good okay i'm just curious
does she not speak english
i do see one thing i notice about i see
a lot of
che guevara cesar chavez kind of like
socialist
stuff i see a lot of art on the wall i
even saw
i wasn't able to take a picture of it
but i saw like anti-american
street art so one interesting fact about
nicaragua
is there's almost no youtube videos
about it
there's no dude don't even look it up
rice no
i i i don't care i haven't i don't
[ __ ] care
i've never seen a video on youtube about
venezuela
see how many let me see how many pages
come up
[Music]
there's no videos he's not going to find
one
nicaragua 2020 nicaragua travel guide
nicaragua de mar
democracy crisis uh asi san juan
nicaragua nicaragua top ten seven pla
top seven places to visit nicaragua ten
shocking visits uh
nicaragua visiting nicaragua six reasons
why people are really equating to
nicaragua abandoning boy near the board
of nicaragua uh
30 things okay so a couple but you know
they probably uploaded most of those
after he said this to try to prove him
wrong or something latinos trying food
in nicaragua moved to nicaragua here's
my journey
the truth about living in nicaragua
travel vlog nicaragua
uh marlon joseph and nicaragua you're
just being spiteful uh nicaragua
supplying beef to the us
introducing nicaragua nicaragua's media
crackdown one dollar street food in
nicaragua okay congratulations rory she
found a couple of videos
the best video of nicaragua most
dangerous schools in nicaragua
what i hate the most about nicaragua
geography now nicaragua
why i take a nicaraguan passport uh
el pase nicaragua
uh okay but that's not a lot dude
it's not that many it doesn't stop
scrolling because you know you know it
keeps
you keep scrolling keeps loading no no
if you could
could we please continue on this
adventure with these two dudes here and
see what's going on
i don't i don't know i'm not going to
assume gender my friend
that's not what i do here
type in nicaragua or managua it's just
youtube and you'll find there's
like not many videos there's nothing
i read like 50 of them okay i read 50 of
them
we have no proof that these people did
not upload those things later to make
him look
foolish
maybe david bond brought
so much um brought so much like uh i
guess attention to this
issue maybe that's what it is maybe
they're years old he
highlighted they're years old the
massive lack of videos and people went
you know what does david bond he's got
his finger on the pulse
why aren't there more venezuela moving
maybe he's influencing
other people to make videos and then
back dating them
years you know this this place reminds
me of a joke what do you call a bunch of
black people swimming
there's like one backpacker guy that's
it
in fact when i was trying to research
what this place was like
i was actually kind of freaked out
because i've never been to a place
where there's no youtube videos like no
youtubers go there
i've been to a place where there was no
youtube videos
it was called 2005.
there is a lot of videos i've never been
like i don't even remember a time in
history where i didn't have youtube
he just strikes me as such a [ __ ]
dumb guy he dumped but also like
but like he's a con man in my opinion he
acts like a con man
but he's too stupid to be one yeah he's
not he's not sharp
vloggers or whatever another thing
you'll notice
is there's like police on every corner
with like ak forces i know what kind of
third world country has a bunch of
militaristic looking police standing on
every street corner in the capitol with
with machine guns rice
what kind of shitty banana republic
would have a bunch of like you know
guardsmen
on behalf of the federal government just
marching through the streets of the
capitol with guns
what kind of shitty house of cards is
nicaragua anyway good luck to you guys
over there
sorry i live in america home of the free
land of the free and home of the brave
may have heard of us
hey you'll see police with ak-47s or
shotguns
why is there so many police uh because
biden got elected and uh
maybe it's in nicaragua no i know but
he's just like because by because the
kamala harris and bide administration
asked us specifically to keep an eye out
for trump supporters even in venezuela i
know it's weird
but they're not taking any chances dave
a lot of bad people okay so
the reason we have the police in the
streets is because um
uh recently we had an election and uh
half of the population did not believe
uh the results of the election but the
people who uh
supposedly won the election wanted to
make sure that they could consolidate
their power
so they have a lot of shows of force and
a lot of like
you know military guys walking around
with guns what if she's just way smarter
than him because they want to scare the
people who may want to protest the
outcome of the elections
oh wow yeah but i'm glad i'm from
america dude it's not to deal with
anything like that
yeah i mean it's like look at this
everybody hidden hands got a good point
he's gonna get her killed
yes exactly what is
what do you mean what a strange thing go
to san francisco go to [ __ ] south
beach that's
no that's just normal art deco [ __ ]
yeah i mean it's not
good looking but it's no but but most
stuff's ugly but
it's not crazy if i saw that i wouldn't
be like bro
royce look at that bro does that not
blow your [ __ ] mind
like no not really no it's just stupid
art
does this change she's a regular
i just want to point something out so
anyone get the wrong idea
she's just a regular everyday citizen of
that country
she's just a regular girl man yeah he
probably met her at some
coffee shop at the airport and uh she's
pr you know what i would guess
hudson news she's a student she is a
student she looks like a student she
looks like a student
no always the same interesting
what is it there are special
monuments of the she's using google
translate
she's even speak english she's using
google translate dictator
daniel ortega see our president
oh dictator she's getting so it's pretty
cool like they developed this
relationship like these two are clearly
dating it looks like to me
you know the way they're very being very
lustful with each other
it's really hard that they develop a
relationship like that when they don't
speak the same language you know you
mean a girl yeah i know
like but i feel like you're starting to
imply that maybe they don't have this
connection
in some way i don't know i'm not gonna
make any assumptions i would never do
that
like you've never you've never gone out
uh to a foreign country and in the first
five minutes
struck up a romantic connection with a
woman who has half a shaved head and a
dream catcher tattoo on her ribs
well yeah when i have a lot of money
[Laughter]
i'm paying them yeah i'm not saying he
is but i'm saying some people might be
saying in my case
by the way i love that he's got her
using the word dictator and stuff hidden
hands right he's going to get this
dumped
yeah she's going to do you got to be
careful no i mean joe listen all this
joking [ __ ] aside you really have to be
careful in these countries because if
they see this video the wrong people
this this woman can be in trouble like
in deep trouble oh yeah we hate chavez
and madoro around here they are
dictators they're the worst
i'm planning me my cousin is planning to
kill him jesus christ
there were many more all over managua
but two years ago with all the
revolution that took place the people
threw them away
oh there were more more statues but by
the way
i like you know people uh that you're
hanging out with in foreign countries
they're acting as your tour guide
they love when you make fun of their
accent
they love that right yeah they love it
when you go like yes yes
many see him as a dictator oh yeah
says the chemistry between them is
undeniable it's so it's
it's not funny i feel it i could feel
the chemistry
okay so i know there's gonna be a lot of
you who are gonna laugh at me like david
come on
if you're not educated on the history of
nicaragua no i'm not no i don't have
wikipedia
i couldn't do a cursory search before i
came here yeah like
look bro i mean i'm not saying you gotta
[ __ ] you know take a hundred
question quiz and get 98 questions right
or anything but like
yeah you know david people that are
interesting part of being interesting is
like
people knowing things right isn't that
one of the things that you enjoy about
like interacting with humans is
sometimes you just meet a new person and
you talk to them for a few minutes
and they say something about something
that sticks with you and you go
oh [ __ ] thank you you just taught me
something
that's very cool now i'm gonna know that
forever what an interesting fact
but see dave you uh you go from country
to country with a gopro strapped on your
head and immediately try to sniff out
very questionable looking [ __ ] um
because that's your own your only goal
is bitcoin
and very very questionable looking [ __ ]
and i'm not playing nice nice so
when you are um sort of like a a one
trick pony when you're a one note
when you're just like a shark swimming
and you just want to eat the same thing
every day
uh yeah you end up becoming an old
lonely
sad person who knows nothing about
anything and people don't want to talk
to
so i hope you're saving up that bitcoin
cash buddy
you're gonna need it remember when we
watched that video those black guys that
went to cuba
you know we would say yeah and even
though they were
pretty trashy at least after watching
this guy's videos i respect them on this
level
they weren't pretending they were
picking up hot chicks they were saying
like oh yeah you could just give them a
shirt and they'll [ __ ] you
like they were at least being up front
they were being upfront about what they
were doing it's like
i'm going to i'm talking about them not
you david relax
they were like look hey yeah you know
these women here at this club like if
you give them five bucks like they'll
blow you and stuff
at least they weren't pretending to be
like these [ __ ] suave guys that are
picking up chicks
they were telling you like yeah look
there's a lot of hookers here and you
could just pay for them
i'm not saying that's what you're doing
david i'm just comparing it to something
else
and those guys you know there's guys
like there's other pickup artists that
we've made fun of on the show that we
we've gone after them and and we've
we've mocked them mercilessly
and and and they didn't uh send a a
dodgy probably fake korean attorney
after us and i'm not saying that that's
what i'm not saying he did that
i'm not saying you did that but i'm just
saying those other guys definitely
didn't
yeah i mean i can't think well i can
think of one i won't say who but there
is somebody that did send a dodgy korean
attorney
from a defunct website after us via
email
saying something about things being
slanderous and stuff and yeah when i
because i can't of course you know a
korean um attorney would have
a lot of power in the united states of
america yeah and then like you know you
click on the korean attorney's website
and it takes you to one of those things
where it's like
charter internet search brought no
results
i'm not saying he did that no
i am saying that saying you did in a
hypothetical situation
somebody could have done that
i would also say that i completely
forgot about this guy
and then something made me remember
something and then honestly
something made royce remember and then
what did he do he went ahead and made me
remember
and then he remembered how i remember
and now we both remember now we're all
remembering things we forgot
about you david we didn't remember you
but i'm just saying
and again i'm not saying this is you
david but i'm just
talking just talking in theory right of
course these are all hypothetical
somebody went ahead satire really yeah
if somebody went after me
on the internet right i would probably
have a lawyer contact them
but the kind of lawyer where when you
click on their website it doesn't offer
to let me buy the domain
so usually this domain is available
we're not saying that's what happened
yeah that totally didn't happen
because you know some people i'm not
speaking of david some people you bust
their balls online and you move on and
then yeah everyone's our balls busted
and we live our lives
we go on living our lives but instead
some people
i'm not saying him let me be very clear
here yeah
i got to be very emphatic that royce is
not talking i am not talking about him
but some people realize that the
clips making fun of them are doing
better numbers
than the videos that the burst is
putting out
so when you uh google mystery person's
name
those clips come up higher than the ones
you're trying to push
not you the hypothetical you yeah royal
you if
you will some people not you
go the route of maybe having a fake
attorney try to bully people
and get not him and then we you know
just laugh at them and
piss on their stupid website but uh as a
good example
couple years ago there was a girl i was
making fun of
i was very mean to her on night wave
never met her before
she saw her on facebook saw she had a
facebook fan page
hated her immediately started mocking
her uh you you know
people like her uh just reach out
quietly
and go hey that kind of hurt my feelings
i don't even really know you but uh
that video is now like pulling away from
all my videos and it's the best
the biggest video with me in it and
you're really being horrible to me in it
would you mind taking that down please
and i was like
oh yeah okay now i feel terrible and i
just took the video down
and that woman is marsha's wife
[Laughter]
that was one i felt bad about i was like
i read that one and i was like
well yeah i'll i'll take it down
i didn't do any research on this place
at all
before i came here because i'm a doofus
you look like a superhero yeah
don't i know because i'm already don't
no can i get
i'm going to say a joke i could say a
joke i'm not a joke right yeah her
superhero name is i wonder how much she
costs woman
she's one of the uh remember the uh
when they were to make a sequel to x-men
the new class
and uh she was going to be the mutant
street walker oh wow really
okay cool she could teleport to come out
of your body
and uh and true story um rogue
touched her and had got aids immediately
oh no
gambit stopped talking to rogue after
that rogue had to touch her and then had
to go
touch wolverine to get rid of it it was
a whole thing and then a bunch of people
almost died
somebody's calling her a bar crawler
park roller's
very funny bar crawler's hilarious
um
with bar crawler somebody asked if she
had a floby accident
and then like let's say that this young
woman isn't a hooker
let's just say that she might not be we
don't know
of course right i mean i might be an
astronaut we don't know
nobody knows right um
the thing is like you could still save
it
by being like hey is that a hooker and
be like yeah but i'm not paying her
okay um
can we all just take a moment to
appreciate how much
fabi looks like a dangerous leader of
like a drug cartel or something
you're going to get her murdered
let me take the joking aside for a
second you've said it you're gonna get
this woman
killed you've got to stop she's probably
already dead
what are you doing
just because she looks like a a sub boss
in in a far cry game doesn't mean you
got to keep calling her that
seriously yeah when i met her i was
actually kind of scared i was like oh my
god she has tattoos
she has a bald head where did you meet
her yeah but see when i first met her i
was actually kind of scared you know
because my car
could have declined over and over again
at the coffee shop they said suspicious
suspicious activity at starbucks and uh
i was worried because i couldn't just
stuff bitcoin cash in her [ __ ]
and it's weird because that starbucks
had a 50 fee to take money out
but but that's her game she's very sweet
and then she kills you
then she takes your organ this guy has
no
ability like talent ability to banter
and be funny you know what i mean like
you could just tell
there's a reason why and i'm not again
let's just keep doing this
this old gag not you david i'm not
no no just anybody just saying there are
guys out there let's say somebody named
david dawn
yeah made up name but there are like
guys out there that
that have no charisma no chemistry with
anybody because
they're dumb like you could just tell
he's like every attempt he's ever made
of being funny and stuff like he's lame
and i guarantee you that american women
know how lame certain guys are so
certain guys go to other countries where
there is a huge language barrier a
cultural barrier
and usually some sort of pay-for-play
type situation going on
and it's easier to then fire up the
cameras and go
oh look at how cool i am and then when
there are awkward moments to blame it on
the cultural barrier
all of the language she didn't get my
hilarious
joke about her being the leader of a
drug cartel she just didn't get my
hilarious joke
because of on account of the language
barrier but if you were in america
and you were trying this kind of game
girls would be like
yeah um shut up
somebody is giving her another superhero
name they're calling her lady dick
i stroke know if that's a good one
well i i hope that that was a good david
bond update